قال رئيس الاوكرانيه فلودي مرزيلين انه
اجرى لقاء مثمره مع رئيس الوزراء وزير
الخارجيه القطريه الشيخ محمد بن عبد
الرحمن الثاني واضاف زيلينسكي ان طرفين
ناقش الخطوات اللازمه لضمان الامن الغذائي
العالمي واستمرار مواصله العمل الامن لممر
الحبوب واضاف زيلينس كانهما ناقشا صيغ
السلام وعوده الاطفال الذين تم ترحيلهم
بشكل غير قانوني من جانب روسيا بالاضافه
الى مناقشه خطه اعاده اعمار اوكرانيا
والاستثمارات القطريه
مهما اليوم مع رئيس الوزراء القطري في
كييف وكانت مباحثات مثمره للغايه والاهم
من ذلك اما قطر ستكون معنا في تنفيذ صيغه
السلام وتنضم الى الجهود العالميه
المشتركه اتفقنا على التعاون من اجل عوده
الاطفال الاوكرانيين الذين تم ترحيلهم الى
روسيا كما ناقشنا وضع مبادره حبوب البحر
الاسود من المهم جدا ان لا يكون هناك نقص
وازمات تثيرها روسيا في سوق الغذاء
العالمي فهذه مساله استقرار عالمي واتوجه
بالشكر لقطر على موقفها المسؤول